Hey, everyone, this is
Phil Lord, I'm here with Byron.
My name is Byron Hamel,
I am a 2021 Academy
Nicholl fellow and my script,
Shade of the Grapefruit Tree,
is about a severely abused white
boy with a murderous stepdad
and then his black landlady,
who is obsessed with
science fiction.
And she teaches him to behave
like a robot which empowers him
to confront the bad stepdad.
Oh, there he is. What's happening?
What's up, man?
Hey, really nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you, too.
I read your bio and you've taken
a pretty circuitous route
to professional screenwriting.
It was like I did all these
other things to eventually make
movies, things like journalism.
I was an associate
producer for radio.
I was in a band.
I was a professional actor
for a little bit.
It all applies.
I love that contrast.
You grow up
in the projects,
but then you go to
a fancy art school.
This has been my life.
Like, I love beauty
and like hardship.
Just boom, boom, boom.
You had all these details
that were just seemed like
they were things
that you experienced yourself.
Well, these were
real people know
I based it on the real people
and real events in my life.
I mean, I didn't
literally become a robot
in my real life.
So far.
Yeah, so far I'm working on it.
How long ago did
you start writing that script?
It was this time
last year, actually.
Do you write fast?
It really varies
like it's it's months at a time.
My first drafts that
come out, I want it to be
very pleasing to me.
Does it make my chest go
”Arrgh”
Does it seize me up?
Yeah.
Am I going to cry? The writer?
Is that a big part
of your writing process
that you revise heavily?
I mean, my first draft
is always garbage.
Same here.
I'm a great editor, actually.
And that's where I shine.
So if I make garbage,
it's OK. I can change it.
I don't have the bone anymore
that that says, “Oh,
I feel hurt by your comment.”
You have to have
a lot of humility
because the movie
wants what it wants.
I write with a partner
all the time, and I learned
not to argue with him
about his response to it
and only to try to engage on
like the problem solving.
And that gets really fun
because when you've got
two people in a room
kicking ideas around,
you always come up with
something that neither of you
could have done on your own.
Yup, because you create
a whole new entity.
It's not you,
it's not him or her.
It's like the two
of you together.
You're something else.
My girlfriend, who really is my
creative partner in everything.
It is that partnership
that makes me find
the magic moments
because I didn't
want to write drama.
I wanted to do genre stuff
because I have all these scenes
that would be horribly traumatic
to put a child actor through.
I don't want to be a person
who some child remembers
and hates, you know,
because I put them through that.
Yeah. Like, I've often been to
movies where I'm like,
I'm being punished,
and I thought that you found
a way without pulling
any punches to show
how difficult the situation was.
But alongside it,
you know, this is
what evil looks like,
but this is also what
goodness  looks like.
Mm-Hmm.
The script really
is about the tiny, small things
that a person can do to help
someone who's going through it.
Somebody told me
when I moved to L.A.
follow the green lights, and
I always try to remember that
that when something comes into
your eyeline, pay attention.
You know, opportunities
like this, I get to talk to you,
Are selfishly really
enlightening for me.
So I got a lot out of that.
It's really inspiring.
Reading your, this work,
it opens up our writing
me and Chris, when we
start to think, OK,
what if everybody in this scene
had good intentions?
You've been invited
into somebody's brain,
so you want to leave-
You want to be proud
of what you're leaving there.
You know, now you're going to be
in the position where people
are going to ask you, like,
what helped your writing
turn the corner?
100 percent write
completely from your heart.
Then worry about how it fits
with everyone else later.
Something I try to do
more often is embrace whatever
enters your head,
because it's probably
you're the only guy who's going
that's going to occur to.
It’s the only way to tell a story
that no one else can tell.
And that is how I found my voice
with this script.
It's funny that it's
the thing that broke through for
you is the most personal.
It is.
Well done.
Well, we'll see you around
the campus, I'm sure.
And godspeed.
Do some more, please.
I will. I am.